once you have this idea functions that
are differentiable at certain points or
parts it opens up a variety of other
kinds of things that you can think about
for instance think back to some of the
functions are often more familiar with
and one is where there's continuity but
there isn't necessarily a derivative if
you think back to our old friend y
equals the absolute value of X ok think
about what looks like ok it's always
continuous isn't it there are no brakes
no brakes but because it's piecemeal ok
because it's piecemeal at that point at
the origin what's happening to gradient
no really hmm what does it mean to be a
tangent you want it to just touch right
just touch but it can't be like you
can't just say it's touching at one
point because you just go back over here
okay here's my cube root X this line on
what the origin right these slide
touches at one point and so does this
one and this one and this one in fact
any line any way no not not these
positive with a law a whole bunch of
lines and infant number lines will cut
through just once but they know tangents
at all right what does it really mean to
be a tangent why is it that the y-axis
he's the tangent nothing else
it's about it's about what the gradients
approaching right there isn't a gray in
there there isn't a great in there
and there's also no gradient here okay
but at least here they were approaching
the same thing whereas here is it is it
is a dislike
sorry that's why it was minus X I just
the one to go talk is it that one or is
it this one
and the answer is well neither of them
is sort of you know a more legitimate
claimant to the Crown's okay neither
that will notice there's no tangent at
that point so again this guy is
continuous but not differentiable at the
origin okay now we've been trying to do
this in visual terms but this has become
a bit difficult really the the cliche
the thing that defines it for you all
the time is think about the derivative
think about this guy right if this thing
is not continuous if the derivative is
not continuous then it's not
differentiable at that point okay if on
the other hand it really is then you'll
be fired figure out what the derivative
of this looks like in fact I drew it not
that long ago
what would the gradient function of the
absolute value of X look like tell me
what it looks like over here what's the
green over here
it's 1 right and then of course on the
left hand side it's it's it's negative
negative 1 so can you see here the gray
a function of the absolute value of X is
not continuous therefore the actual
function is not differentiable